it's really difficult isn't it and i
think that's uh your various guests have
have made that point as we just don't
know where this is going i i think that
uh for the russians to come in and try
to seize kiev and
the reaction of the
local populace i suspect is going to be
one of attack i think that they would
initially be scared and will stay in
their their homes but as as time
progresses i think they will come out
and that this is a big city and it's
going to be very very difficult to
control
there's an awful lot of fear here now we
know that the roads heading west away
from kiev are absolutely jam-packed we
know that the airspace is now closed we
understand that the underground is
completely open for free for everyone
who wishes to move around and perhaps
even uh take shelter uh in the
underground so we we are
in a capital city mark that is is is
terrified about what is happening
interestingly though
we've talked about it on a number of
occasions in the last week or so about
how people have carried on life as
normal and that has happened even right
to today with people
still commuting into work i think in the
coming hours that's going to change
dramatically i think that people are
going to be extremely scared but we
still have we know this invasion is
underway but we're still waiting to see
um
clearer uh evidence of what's happening
um how many russian uh soldiers are
involved in this um attack and what the
uh ukrainian military are going to do to
to repulse it the as your guest previous
guest just said the army is much better
than it was in 2014 then it was actually
pretty hopeless they are certainly more
professional and we know that they have
been given an awful lot of supplies uh
from the west
but how they react in the in the coming
hours we simply don't know
interestingly
as well you know we had these explosions
we heard the noises we heard jets in the
sky um a few hours ago but it's gone
much quieter again and uh
what happens next we just don't know but
it's it's it's it's really hard to judge
this is a very peculiar place
right now and
i think
things are going to become clearer
but that you know that could take days
as we see whether this invasion is a
full-on one
whether it's an incursion whether it
grows it appears that it's a big one but
we just don't know at the stage and we
don't know how uh ukraine is going to
react to it or for that matter how the
western world is going to react as well